>> Hannity: NOW CHARGED WITH
ASSAULT WITH A GUN SHAPED KNIFE
AND LUNCHING AT THE COMEDIAN
DURING A STAND-UP ROUTINE AND OF
COURSE INCREDIBLY SMART AND
STABLE LADIES OF THE VIEW THEY
KNOW EXACTLY WHO TO BLAME.
WHAT YOU THINK?
DONALD TRUMP?
>> WHAT YOU THINK IS HAPPENING?
IT'S HAPPENING ON AIRPLANES,
IT'S HAPPENING ON STREET
CORNERS, PEOPLE ARE JUST
RUNNING, I MEAN THE
HOLLYWOOD BOWL, IS MAN UP THERE.
>> THE PANDEMIC, THE OPIOID
CRISIS, THE FACT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS OUT THERE
SAYING THINGS LIKE JUST KNOCK
THE HELL OUT OF THEM I SWEAR
THAT THEY'LL PAY FOR THE LEGAL
FEES.
>> THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
THING, I KNOW YOU WANT TO WRAP
IT ALL THE POLITICS THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT SECURITY.
>> THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN BEFORE.
>> WASN'T PARTICULARLY
RIGHT-LEANING AND SMACKING CHRIS
ROCK.
>> DONALD TRUMP RELEASED ON
CIVILITY.
>> Hannity: UNFORTUNATELY
JOYLESS BUT HARD IS NOT FROM HER
DONALD TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME THANKFULLY
HILARIOUSLY FUNNY I HOPE HE IS
OKAY HOWEVER HIS ATTACKERS NOT
LOOKING SO GOOD THE ASSAILANT
SUFFERED MULTIPLE INJURIES
DURING THE IMPACT INCLUDING AN
ARM THAT LOOKS NOW YOU ATTACK SN
INNOCENT PERSON YOU MIGHT WANT
TO ATTACK EXPECT TO GET THE ADAM
SCHIFF KICKED OUT OF YOU.
COMING UP PIERS MORGAN WILL GET
HIS REACTION ALSO DHS SECRETARY
ON CAPITOL HILL AGAIN TODAY
WHERE THEY STRUGGLED YET AGAIN
TO EXPLAIN WHAT HE HIRED A FAR
LEFT ACTIVIST AND JOE BIDEN'S
MINISTRY OF TRUTH THE LOWLIFES
THAT'S COME UP STRAIGHT-AHEAD
BUTTER TOPS OR AT NIGHT COMES
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE APPARENTLY
OUR COGNITIVE STRUGGLING
COMMANDER THEY REPRESENT THE
MOST EXTREME POLITICAL FACTION
IN AMERICAN HISTORY BECAUSE OF
THEM WILL KIDS WILL SOON BE
BANNED FROM GOING TO SCHOOL AND
JUST MADE THIS ALL OUT.
>> THIS IS ABOUT A LOT MORE THAN
ABORTION.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU HAVE SHE
STATES CHANGING THE LAW THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE LGBTQ CAN BE IN
CLASSROOMS OF OTHER CHILDREN.
IS THAT LEGIT UNDER THE WAY THAT
THE DECISIONS ARE MADE?
WHAT ARE THE NEXT THINGS ARE TO
BE ATTACKED BECAUSE THIS MEGA
CROWD IS REALLY THE MOST EXTREME
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
EXISTED IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Hannity: IN AMERICAN
HISTORY WILL DEAL WITH THAT IN A
MINUTE BUT THAT'S PREDICTABLE
DEMOCRATIC ALLY, WE USED TO GET
EVERY TWO YEARS, FOUR YEARS,
REPUBLICANS ARE RACIST,
MISOGYNIST, XENOPHOBIC,
TRANS-PHOBIC, YOU KNOW THE
ROUTINE.
BUT A THAT OBAMA SAID THOSE
PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA THE
PEOPLE THAT THINK THAT THERE
BIBLES AND RELIGIONS ARTILLERY
CALLED BASKET OF CHIPS TO.
HER FBI ONCE REFERRED TO
CONSERVATIVES AS FROM SUPPORTING
SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS.
THEY ARE THE MOST EXTREME
POLITICAL FACTION IN HISTORY?
HALF THE COUNTRY JOE?
THEN OF COURSE JOE BIDEN JUST
SAID IS A SIMPLE DISGUSTING
POLITICAL SCARE TACTIC NO BASIS
IN REALITY, HE IS DEMOED GAGGING
IN THE MOST DISHONEST WAY
POSSIBLE IN FACT RUTH GATOR
GINSBURG HERSELF ONCE ALL BUT
PURRED ADDICTED THAT ROE V. WADE
WOULD BE OVERTURNED BECAUSE IT'S
ON SHAKY LEGAL GROUNDS AND FOR
DECADES GET THIS, JOE BIDEN
HIMSELF ACTUALLY AGREED WITH
SEAN HANNITY AND HE WANTED ROVE
HE WADE TOSSED OUT ON A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT,
WHERE'S THE MEDIA MOB ASKING
JOE BIDEN WHAT MADE HIM CHANGE
HIS MIND IN THE 70s, AND
SENATOR BIDEN SAID THAT I DON'T
LIKE THE SUPREME COURT DECISION
ON ABORTION, I THINK YOU WENT
TOO FAR, I DO THINK THAT A WOMAN
HAS THE SOLE RIGHT TO SAY WHICH
IT HAPPENED TO HER BODY.
IN THE 1980s, HE SUPPORTED
THAT CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
WITH THE RECENTLY PASSED ORANGE
HATCH OF UTAH AND A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
BANNED ROE V. WADE AND LETTING
STATES DECIDE ABORTION LAW, AND
IN 2006, JOE HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT ABORTION TAKE A LOOK.
>> TELL ME ABOUT ABORTION, WHAT
YOU STAND AND HOW WE FACE AT
ISSUE?
>> CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT, I DO
NOT VIEW ABORTION AS A IS A
CHOICE AND A RIGHT.
I THING IT'S A TRAGEDY.
>> Hannity: NOT A CHOICE YOU
ARE RIGHT ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN
EVENTS AND MORE RECENTLY
YESTERDAY HE REFERRED TO
ROE V. WADE AS THE ABILITY TO
ABORT A CHILD.
NOT A FETUS, A CLUMP OF CELLS,
BUT A CHILD.
HE WAS THE WORD, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA THAT WORKING TO MAKE
THE JUDGMENT THAT IS GONNA SAY
THAT NO ONE CAN MAKE THE
JUDGMENTS TO ABORTED CHILD BASED
ON A DECISION BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
THE ITS WAY OVERBOARD.
SHE PROPAGANDA WAS CHECK OUT HER
ANSWER.
>> WISE A PRESIDENT TSAI ABOUT
THE JUDGMENT TO CHOOSE TO
ABORTED CHILD?
>> THE PRESENCE OF YOU ON A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO MAKE CHOICES
ABOUT HER OWN HEALTH CARE IS
WELL-KNOWN, WELL DOCUMENTED, AND
WELL STATED.
>> I UNDERSTAND PETER BUT IT'S
WHAT HIS POSITION.
I CANNOT SAY THIS IS NOT A
POLITICAL ISSUE WHEN THE
PRESIDENT STATEMENT ABOUT THIS
IS PRO-CHOICE OFFICIALS ELECTED.
>> THAT I SAY IS ON A POLITICAL
ISSUE?
>> YES YOU SAID DON'T CALL IT A
POLITICAL ISSUE IS NOT.
>> Hannity: NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS WHAT HE THINGS ABOUT
ABORTION OR FRANKLY IN THAT
MATTER.
HE MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW ANY OF
THIS HIMSELF BUT THE MARCHING
ORDERS HAVE BEEN ISSUED AND THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
HELL-BENT ON LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND USING THIS
ISSUE TO BLAME VOTERS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
LATE LAST NIGHT TAKE A LOOK.
>> THOSE ARE PUBLIC AND LEADERS
WERE TRYING TO WEAPONIZE THE
YOUTH OF THE LAW AGAINST WOMEN.
WHAT WE SAY HOW DARE THEY.
HOW DARE THEY TELL A WOMAN BUT
THEY CAN DO NOT DO WITH HER OWN
BODY.
HOW DARE THEY.
HOW DARE THEY TRY TO STOP HER
FROM DETERMINING OWN FUTURE.
HOW DARE THEY.
TRY TO DENY WOMEN,ABORTION WILLN
AMERICA AND MOST OTHER PLACES.
BY THE WAY IF IT IS OVERTURNED
ABORTION WILL STILL BE TOTALLY
LEGAL IN MOST EVERY STATE,
ABORTION ACCESS WILL EXIST FOR
EVERY AMERICAN SO THE QUESTION
IS WHY THE DEMI GOGGIN THE ISSUE
AND LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
IS EVERYONE OF THEIR POLICIES
HAVE FAILED.
THUS A DISTRACTION.
NOW IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE?
YES.
TWO PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF PASSION
VIEWS ON IT, YES.
SHOULD BE LEGAL IN AMERICA?
YES.
THEY ALL HAVE THE MOST LIBERAL
LAWS AND WHILE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE EVENLY DIVIDED ON THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS ARE DEEPLY
WORRIED ABOUT OTHER THINGS YOU
KNOW, LIKE THE ECONOMY.
HIGHEST GAS PRICES WE'VE EVER
PAID, HIGH PRICES, THE HIGHEST
PRICES WE PAID FOR EVERYTHING
THAT WE BIND EVERY STORE WE GO
TO.
THE DISASTER IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE WAR IN EUROPE, THE CRISIS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, POOR
LEADERSHIP IN D.C.
NOW THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
DIRECTLY IMPACT EVERY AMERICAN,
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND BY THE WAY
THEY KNOW WHO TO BLAME.
JOE BIDEN IS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER IN EVERY POLL SHOWS IT.
SO ALL THE DEMOCRATS THE MEDIA
MOB THEY WANT TO INFLAME THEIR
EMOTIONS, THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON
ONLY ONE TOPIC, THEY NEVER WANT
TO TALK ABOUT ANY OF THE
FAILURES OF JOE BIDEN AS A
MATTER FACT THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA THEY COVER FOR JOE BIDEN,
DELTA YOU THAT THE WORLD IS
COMING TO AN END, IT IS NOT
TRUE.
WILL TRY TO USE ABORTION AS A
POLITICAL WEDGE AND LIED TO YOU
AND THEN YOU REALIZE OH ABORTION
IS STILL LEGAL THE STATES
DECIDE.
WE WILL TELL YOU THE COLD HARD
TRUTH SEPARATE FACT FROM
FICTION.
WE'LL BRING YOU THE FACTS AND
COVER ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT
IMPACT YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
THE LEFT HAS LOST TOUCH WITH
REALITY, THEY HAVE NO GOOD STORY
TO TELL, OBAMA, HILLARY, YOU
JUST NEED TO TELL A STORY THEY
DON'T HAVE A STORY TO TELL.
UNLESS THE MAKE ONE UP.
IT'S ONLY ONE WAY TO BRING THEM
BACK TO EARTH AND THAT'S FOR YOU
TO THE PEOPLE TO SHOW UP, AT THE
POLLS, VOTE THEM OUT OF OFFICE
IN SIX MONTHS, IF YOU'VE NOT
REGISTERED I STRONGLY SUGGEST
YOU DO IT NOW.
BECAUSE IN THESE SIX MONTHS WERE
NOW FACING A VERY PIVOTAL
INFLATION POINT IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN PIVOTABLE, TURNING POINT
ELECTION.
GET THIS RIGHT NOW AS OF TONIGHT
EVERY CIVIL CANDIDATE THAT
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP HAS
ENDORSED IN THE PRIMARY, LOOK A